生菜雷德桑创作填满杯一张
我们爱琳雷文萨拍到最后最文三好
最后一场哦
大家可笑可笑耶
记住十秒
98764321走
♪ 摊开手机答案 ♪
hello啊
晚安晚安
你现在心情如送你两颗星星
这就是我现在的心情
就是再晚都还是要来看看呵呵
看看我们的舞台
看看嗯
辛苦的工作人员没大家目前的进度哦
在应该在四在事故了
现在中原标准时间
OK晚上11.41分
我们1.0的时候是周周飞
每周一场
然后一个月就是四场
然后2.0算是隔周飞
这些见面的日子好像已经变成我们的日常了
然后对回到了台北小巨蛋
一晃眼哦
就又回来了
2.0出发的时候有个钓台
然后这次再回到小巨蛋
又有一个新的吊牌
就是我的非天堂木屋
四档测试是四档
现在二档
现在二嘛快很多
快很多
比刚刚没台快追一轮啊
没有他打到四挡的时候
对瓶子可能是斜的哦
还不是边吼
我是开玩笑的哈
我是开玩笑
是因为存折才这样
真的不怕快
是可以两个人的吗
可以啊
当然可以呀
可是我就变成要跟你
哎嘿哎包
My dream
I see you
I see you see you
拜拜
♪ 你是认真的吗 ♪
♪ 我想再确定一遍 ♪
我回来了都回来了
我好安全
这我安捂着嘴就说吧
♪ 我还原一出真爱 ♪
♪ 心房空缺 ♪
准备微轮不到我
然后今天个个都还在熬夜
我也只能先回去了
早一点休息
就现在已经凌晨一点了
对时间见
争取早点休息
然后其实中午就要来了
明天中午就会来
明天中午见
拜拜晚安晚安再见
啊咖啡
Tell me
真有睡好吗
在放松的音乐之下睡得还蛮好的
就从百倍这边可以喊出来
因为等于最后一次跳百倍啊
你懂意思吗
最后最后最后一次跳
你就想说你多走一次
你要确定啊不行
忍住忍住忍住
好哥
等会我们准备进行123
♪ 我还在这里切 ♪
♪ 来得及后 ♪
特别想要这个by back
I'm back
Guys
The top
I'm back
♪ 到时间就出击 ♪
♪ I'm back ♪
过一次基
你在台下
这下面最后一次
明天后天还有内
嘿嘿嘿哎哎我不是命中注定
♪ 自由是我的天性 ♪
对世界充满好奇
你你你你你你你baby anymore
好冷哦
这时候就羡慕他们了
都长袖回家被冷死了
在外面玩的时候都不能浴袍
对啊是个嗨
是个嗨
好谢谢大家
但在此之前我想要跟懒懒说
祝你生日快乐啊
这他是生日
郑绍兴
现在过12点了
对不对
他害羞了啦啊啊
快去追她
你们干的好
他走不掉喽
祝你生日快乐
最后祝你生日快乐啊
谢谢谢谢大家
谢谢所有的老师们
谢谢辛苦啦
这几天
接下来这两天让我们好好的完美的完成它吧
谢谢你们
这20年以来我终于可以见到你了
我带女儿连续3年都有来听你的演唱会
我也想像她一样会唱歌
从第二张专辑到现在
我喜欢王静茹
从国3~3高
感谢你出现在我的生命
怕大家晚上会一起哭
众人舍不得啊
演唱会的灯总有一天会关
但是我们的故事都会继续下去
无论你唱到什么时候
我们也会永远陪伴你
You are my only love
爱你爱你
终于小巨蛋我们回来了
这个巡演等于是三度回到了小巨蛋
然后从1.0到2.0的出发
然后到现在呃
这个最终章马上就要来了
所以今天晚上我们还是要用我们最美的姿态
把最完美的我们呈现给小巨蛋的观众
朋友们
你们好好哇啊啊啊哎哎哎哎哎哎哎拜拜
♪ 开始游戏 ♪
♪ 到时间就出击 ♪
♪ HIB拜拜 ♪
♪ 那一瞬间我睁开眼睛 ♪
Say it right
还道具参加321走
没看到他讲没有啊
他一直没有下来吗
经过了一分半了
你们再确定一下哦
有的有的再确认是不是挺收到对
那不知道问题原因是什么
对不对
可是我在评估他代表他上分
对待会开到一半会不会又停诶
没把握
因为在是歪的
那我们就不要下来了
上去上去上去上来哎
停停停停
越来越弯
上去上去上去
等下这首完啊
先按场
然后我跟乐手老师说一下
好
收到先按场先
如果我们绕场吊牌有点问题
我们有可能不能走到场
我们要走往幸福出发吗
嗯我们走旧的版本往幸福出发哦
那我原神台照旧对对跟走哦
诶诶野生台没有起来走走走走
那个荧光棒是关掉荧光关
我没有开
那个是没有信号的样子
总共八个人去小姐旁边
然后跟着他闹场
对还是一样
原本的号热爱热爱
帮我先快步的去
Stand by
其实今天台上有发生一些状况
很考验我们大家的默契
本来我们准备了一个返场的调台
我相信这边也有一些人可能有发现
所以刚才往我们中间其实断了很长一段时间
然后嗯舞者们后来三三两两的往上签
那些都是我们没有排练过的
那我想要给我的工作伙伴们
我的舞者们掌声鼓励
因为我们还是希望能够在时间内
能够把这个调台呈现给你们
所以他们一直在及时的很快抢救
但是有一点点可惜的是
确定抢救的这个过程中
这个机器呢它还是没有办法这么安全的做动
所以我真的不可能让大家陪我一起
冒着这个风险
因为钓台他会四处环绕
可是我还是很想要把这些准备好
钓台的这个还唱的歌唱给你们听
我想下去走完
唱完这些歌靠近你们好不好
呜呜呜呜
太帅了
呜呜啊啊
没了没了呜呜
呜呜呜三三呜
谢谢大家了
最特别的最特别之最特别的在台北小巨蛋
2.0是回来最终章的第一场
最特别的最的特别
语无伦次
一切都是最好的安排啊
大家好棒
打死
都吃饱了
你有睡饱吗
没有啊
好累啊
好OK没问题好
那你帮我看一下机械的程度
其实舞台下的大家
真的是每一个人都非常非常的紧绷
舞台上的我们就是任何状况随时都有可能发生
然后就考验着自己的反应能力啊
然后团队的默契反应啊
我听到他跟我说的时候
这样才有问题
要不要FMV的时候
我就说好
因为我知道他一定是努力到最后一刻
没有办法了
然后一座捂着三三两两的上台
可是他们都还可以接受
这样我觉得是真的是很动人的团队默契
昨天太crazy了
一切都太crazy了
精彩对
但是好啦
大家大家辛苦了
每个人都很想就是很很想让他完美
对不对
我们今天必须的必须昨天说
你会吗
真的会吗
好我们就开始就很好看好
大家今年一定我们心今天一定要努力想办法
让他所有的事情都完美
加油加油
哎呦
子凯多单位辛苦了耶耶有睡的没睡的
我们都打起精神来
♪ 这孤单太完美 ♪
♪ 黎明的安慰 ♪
♪ 不知道替我祝福的人 ♪
♪ 他是谁 ♪
最难忘的就是这个团队
因为这个团队是我带过的最有爱的团队
没有之一哦
是最因为所有人都一条心想把这件事做好
所以感觉到大家的热情
感觉到大家的努力
大家的尽力
这两年最大的收获就是认识这一群人
还是会很不舍得
毕竟上次就已经互爆了
所以我保证今天可以装完整的下班
哈哈毕业了不行
我不会毕业
我永远不会毕业
就下次还要再捅吗
你先看这只球赛
最大的收获就是他们
我等一下应该身上
那就会哭了
对不起
不能反问我娘都哭了
哈哈刚彩排在爱你的时候就已经哭了
不知道我对自己说伤心之后
♪ 另一次机会我会全心的奉陪 ♪
♪ 我对自己说伤心之后另一次机会 ♪
♪ 谢谢这孤单 ♪
的美好哟
那没问题的话
昨天有个小风波
今天一定顺耶
这个真的是最终场了
所有的感受就在今天
能量全部给他宣泄出来
然后最完美最漂漂亮亮的手环
今天一定会非常顺利
非常难忘
非常完美
Who is ng g g
Who is this jeis
♪ This ♪
♪ 开始游戏 ♪
♪ 到时间就出击 ♪
♪ 拜拜 ♪
Fight
♪ 那一瞬间我睁开眼 ♪
♪ I'm a i'm a take a fight ♪
♪ 欢迎来city party ♪
♪ Cindy cindy ♪
♪ Cindy ♪
让你伤心
♪ 怎么可以 ♪
♪ Cindy cindy ♪
♪ 有快递 ♪
♪ 咿呀咿呀哟 ♪
♪ 失恋失恋了 ♪
♪ 安利咿呀咿呀哟 ♪
你出个主意做主意
头顶有一哎呦
♪ 你可爱的船是铁达尼 ♪
我的轮回一中需要做队友
约定好开心
♪ 我的爱走不停都有赖在一起 ♪
你们不能这样子
我我你们我我不能看到他们
我还有很开心的一票要继续
你们去旁边冷静一下
四无自由
♪ 不能变回来 ♪
变成了今天是施乐害的最终章了
我想请台上所有的伙伴们一起走到台前
我们一起走过了855天
算是一个城市79场演出
这趟旅程成为了我身边的各位
你们的生活
也成为了我的生活
谢谢每一位优秀的你们
谢谢谢谢你们和我一起走过这一段
谢谢你们
谢谢台北
♪ 如果有一天我回到从前 ♪
♪ 回到最原始的我 ♪
♪ 你是否会觉得我不错 ♪
♪ 如果有一天我离你遥远 ♪
♪ 不能再和你相约 ♪
♪ 你是否会发觉我已经说再见 ♪
♪ 当你的眼睛眯着笑 ♪
♪ 当你喝可乐 ♪
♪ 当你尝 ♪
♪ 我想对你好 ♪
♪ 你从来不知道想你想你也能成为嗜好 ♪
♪ 当你说今天的烦恼 ♪
♪ 当你说夜深你睡不着 ♪
♪ 我想对你说 ♪
♪ 却害怕都说错 ♪
♪ 好喜欢你 ♪
♪ 知不知道 ♪
♪ 如果有一天梦想都实现 ♪
♪ 回忆都成了永远 ♪
♪ 你是否还会记得今天 ♪
♪ 如果有一天我们都发觉原来什么都可以 ♪
♪ 我们是否还会停留在这里 ♪
♪ 当你的眼睛眯着笑 ♪
♪ 当你喝可乐 ♪
♪ 当你吵 ♪
♪ 我想对你好 ♪
♪ 你从来不知道想你想你也能成为嗜好 ♪
♪ 当你说今天的烦恼 ♪
♪ 当你说夜深你睡不着 ♪
♪ 我想对你说 ♪
♪ 却害怕都说错 ♪
♪ 好喜欢你 ♪
♪ 知不知道 ♪
♪ 谢谢大家啦 ♪
谢谢呜呜哦吼谢谢王谢蕾耶来啦
谢谢礼
拿去晒一杯耶啊
耶毕业快乐
耶
夏夏夏夏夏夏夏夏夏夏
Everybody shash
啊太好笑了
还忘掉了
我也而且龙一出来了
说明明是一个很欢乐的场合
结果我反而哭了一